we're now officially less than one month
away from apple's wwdc event on june 6th
and i honestly think that this will be
the best wwc in years not only because
of some highly anticipated software
updates like ipad os 16 but also because
we're expecting some brand new macs so
what i'm going to do in this video is
cover everything you should be expecting
to come at wwdc as well as my personal
thoughts speculations and software
feature requests so let's jump right
into it first of all i believe that this
is going to be the year where apple goes
all out trying to make their consumers
as happy as possible with their products
in an attempt to keep sales up as much
as possible just in case there's lower
demand or a potential recession like i
talked about in a previous video so i
think they're going to be giving us some
amazing software features that they've
been holding off on for years and the
biggest software update i'm expecting is
ipad os 16 so before we get into the
potential hardware releases we should be
expecting let's jump into software first
starting with ipad os 16. now the first
thing i'm the most excited for is the
new leaks for a mac os like pro mode
which basically turns your ipad into a
more pro computer that's kind of like
mac os with better multitasking and
better features and the reason we think
that's coming is because of some leaked
patents where apple actually showed off
a mac os like interface on the ipad and
max went in depth into that in a
previous video but we also have leaks
from imagine boo who believes that the
pro mode will be limited to m1 chip
ipads which is now the ipad air and the
ipad pro as well as any future m chip
ipads coming later on now the pro mode
will initiate when you grab your ipad
and connect it to the magic keyboard
case or a third-party keyboard that also
has a trackpad like logitech's folio
touch which is a great budget option and
then as soon as you put your ipad on it
it switches over to that mode
automatically giving you better more pro
features multitasking and a bunch of
stuff like potentially even little mini
windows for apps so you can have them
hover around while you do other things
now on top of that i think that apple is
finally going to be giving pro apps from
mac os
to the ipad pro and maybe even the ipad
air the m-chip ipads including final cut
pro logic and xcode which is something
that john prosser leaked a couple of
years back now i don't think that
they're going to be the full versions
but rather brand new ipad optimized
versions that can save data over the
cloud so you can work on projects across
your mac or your ipad and i think this
is going to be a huge deal for ipad
sales especially the ipad pros now other
than that i'm also hoping for updates to
the files app including a new eject
button for ssds because the system right
now is absolutely terrible you can't
eject ssds so we ended up having issues
with corruption and problems where the
ssd just won't show up now on top of
that i'm also hoping for better external
display support with it finally being
able to change the aspect ratio to 16 by
nine automatically to match your display
and not have the weird just square-ish
aspect ratio from the ipad now with that
said let's move over to ios 16 for the
iphone and to be honest i'm actually
pretty happy already with ios 15 but
there are a couple of things that i'd
like to see first of all the big feature
that i really really want is an
always-on display mode for the iphone 14
pro coming later this year and maybe
even for older models who knows but i
think the iphone 14 pro for sure because
it's rumored to be getting a display
that goes down to one hertz refresh rate
which is perfect for always on mode now
on top of that i have a personal feature
request which is being able to mark text
messages as unread because right now
it's so annoying that we don't have this
feature because i literally will avoid
opening a message if i'm too busy to
read it and dedicate time to reply just
in case i forget to reply later so i
don't even open it now other than that
one feature that's really interesting is
potential crash detection so if you get
into a car accident your iphone could
detect that and automatically notify
your emergency contacts or in the worst
case
dial 911 for you just in case you're
passed out in your car off the side of a
cliff or something like that it could
literally save so many lives now on top
of that apple lab recently made some
brand new ios 16 concepts so let's go
through some of the features that he
imagined and showed off as you can see
there's better multitasking being able
to split the screen there's redesign
notifications a bunch of different
redesigned apps we've also got new
widgets and basically a bunch of other
quality of life improvements so
hopefully we get those with ios 16. now
moving on to watch os 9 of course there
is going to be new watch faces and
there's also a chance that the older
faces will get fully redesigned because
i'm expecting the apple watch series 3
with the square display to finally get
discontinued so now we're only going to
have the rounded larger displays which
is going to be really nice for the
entire apple watch lineup moving on mark
german also thinks we're getting an
expanded low power mode for watch west 9
that works with more apps and features
because right now we only have the power
reserve feature that only lets you
access the time which is a bit annoying
so hopefully the new low power mode
gives you more options on top of that we
should be expecting more health related
features like a new detection feature
for atrial fibrillation as well as
additional workout types and of course
we might get the new crash detection
feature on the apple watch as well which
is going to be a big deal now on top of
that with the release of the series 8
later this year we might be getting
temperature monitoring but unfortunately
there might be a chance that it's only
for the women's health cycle tracking
app but who knows and we are expected to
get satellite texting and calling on the
apple watch as well as the iphone but
other than that we don't really know
that much else so let's finally move
over to the actual hardware releases
that we're likely to see at wwdc
first of all mark grumman believes that
apple is gearing up to launch some new
macs in the next few months and what
better place to do so than at wwdc but
in terms of max mark is expecting to get
released he believes that one of them is
the new macbook air which i think could
come with the m2 chip and a full
redesign which you can see in these
renders we had created for us based on
my own speculations so that means max a3
new color options white bezels with a
notch and more now the other mac that
mark german thinks could be coming could
be a new redesigned mac mini a 24 inch
imac or a 13 inch macbook pro now in my
opinion especially based on recent leaks
and reports the 24 inch imac might not
get replaced until 2023
with the m3 chip now other than that the
other big product we could get instead
is a brand new apple silicon mac pro
with a brand new quad die chip and
that's because apple literally mentioned
it during their last march event that
they were working on it and leaving it
for another day so wwdc would be perfect
on top of that ross young who is
currently the most accurate apple leaker
for display leaks believes that a new
27-inch mini led display
will be announced at wwec alongside the
new mac pro which totally makes sense to
me however some other reliable analysts
like michiko believe that we won't be
seeing any desktop macs including the
mac pro the imac pro and the mac mini
until 2023 so i guess we're just gonna
have to wait and see what happens but if
you're excited for wwdc especially the
new software like ipad os 16 go ahead
and let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below and click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out those
new ipad patents right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video